На прощання грюкнули дверима.
Адміністрація Дональда Трампа в останній день своєї роботи перед церемонією інавгурації нового президента США Джо Байдена
вперше застосувала санкції проти будівництва російського газопроводу "Північний потік-2".
Штрафні заходи, якими Сполучені Штати досі лише погрожували, але до яких ще жодного разу не вдавалися,
стосуватимуться судна-трубоукладача "Фортуна", а також його власника - компанії "КВТ-Рус".
Про це повідомило міністерство економіки Німеччини. Інформацію про запровадження санкцій міністерство отримало від посольства США у ФРН.
В американському посольстві наголосили, що Вашингтон - цитата - "рішуче налаштований вжити всіх необхідних заходів,
щоб зупинити будівництво газопроводу "Північний потік-2",
який загрожує важливим національним інтересам європейських партнерів і США". Кінець цитати.
На цьому тлі з'явився меморандум "Газпрому" до нового розміщення єврооблігацій,
в якому зазначається, що компанія допускає припинення або повне скасування будівництва "Північного потоку-2" через політичний тиск.
Представник американського посольства у Берліні Джозеф Джордано-Шольц також зазначив,
що затримання російського опозиціонера Олексія Навального зміцнило позицію США.
За його словами, це стало "ще одним чітким сигналом, що поведінка Росії не змінюється".
Американський представник також закликає Німеччину переоцінити свою позицію щодо газопроводу.
Після резонансного отруєння Олексія Навального в Німеччині і Європі почалися дискусії про можливе введення санкцій проти газогону.
При цьому як у ЄС, так і в самій Німеччині єдиної позиції з цього питання немає.
Для тих політиків, які і так виступали проти будівництва "Північного потоку-2" отруєння,
нинішній арешт російського опозиціонера є додатковими аргументами проти цього проєкту.
Зараз настав крайній строк, щоб чітко вказати, де межа.
Німеччина нарешті має відмовитися від свого особливого шляху - робити ставку на "Північний потік-2".
Ми ж не можемо допустити, щоб така непередбачувана влада відповідала за нашу енергетичну безпеку.
Цього не повинно статися. "Північний потік" - давня причина розладу всередині Європи, від нього потрібно відмовитися.
І ситуація з Навальним робить зрозумілим кожному, чому це необхідно.
У консервативному блоці Анґели Меркель ХДС/ХСС також лунають голоси про перегляд ставлення до газогону.
Я думаю, що ми значною мірою вичерпали режим санкційних заходів.
І ми, німці, досягли тієї межі, коли необхідно критично поглянути на проєкт "Північний потік-2".
Інші політики, зокрема соціал-демократи, традиційно вважають, що отруєння Олексія Навального не має до енергетичного проєкту жодного відношення.
Одне з іншим ніяк не пов'язано. "Північний потік-2" майже готовий. Є причини бути як за нього, так і проти.
Але я не вважаю, що потрібно змішувати енергетичну політику з санкціями.
Якщо вже про це і говорити серйозно, то потрібно було б одразу ж ввести нафтогазове ембарго проти Росії.
Тому така фіксація на проєкті "Північний потік-2", який ще навіть не готовий, виглядає не зовсім чесно.
І думаю, що в минулі роки ми бачили, що енергетична політика непридатна для санкцій.
Східний комітет німецької економіки випустив пресреліз, в якому йдеться про те,
що вони не здивовані санкціями США в останній день роботи адміністрації Дональда Трампа.
Чи вдасться залагодити конфлікт навколо енергетичного проєкту з адміністрацією нового президента - поки сказати складно.
Але добре відомо, що Джо Байден на посаді віцепрезидента США за Барака Обами також різко критикував "Північний потік-2"
і називав його принципово невигідною угодою для Європи.